[Música]
Bienvenidos a este especial de Franz 24
Venezuela afronta el año 2023 con la
expectativa de que el diálogo que
mantienen representantes del gobierno y
la oposición pueda encontrar una
solución para la crisis política que
afecta al país y que ha derivado en
problemas sociales y económicos si bien
algunos especialistas se han centrado en
el hecho de que la crisis ha sido más
evidente desde la llegada al poder de
Nicolás maduro otro grupo de analistas
sitúan los orígenes de esta en los
primeros años del entonces presidente
Hugo Chávez cuando en un primer momento
no le da importancia a un alto
porcentaje de la población que no estuvo
de acuerdo con sus medidas que fueron
implementadas bajo el amparo de una
nueva constitución que entre otras cosas
extendió el período presidencial con
reelección inmediata
a esta hora le damos la bienvenida al
analista político Joel ortamoros Saludos
señor Joel Bienvenido a France 24 y le
pregunto Qué impacto pudo tener el
establecimiento de una nueva Carta Magna
en la crisis política que Se generó en
Venezuela
Por supuesto que en el momento que ASUME
el presidente Chávez entonces la
conducción del país y anuncia la
realización de un referéndum para ir al
proceso Constituyente proceso
Constituyente que
justamente hace nacer una nueva
constitución que es la constitución
de el año 99 que
deroga la del año 61 que venía de ser la
Constitución con mayor estabilidad
política y en el tiempo desde el inicio
de la República de Venezuela
allí entonces
comienza después del apoyo que tuvo el
presidente Chávez de los sectores
económicos de los sectores empresariales
que estaban también agotados
de el manejo
del bipartidismo sobre la democracia
venezolana comienzan a tratar de
manejarlo quizás a tratar de tratar de
manipularlo probablemente
pensaron que iba a ser una persona mucho
más dócil de lo que en efecto era y
empieza entonces la ruptura entre el
presidente Chávez y el diario El
Nacional por ejemplo radio Caracas
televisión para hablar de medios de
comunicación
pero poco tiempo después de ser aprobada
la Constitución un sector de la
población expresó su malestar saliendo a
las calles en abril de 2002 luego llamó
a un paro nacional orientado al sector
petrolero en diciembre de ese mismo año
y votó en contra de la continuidad de
Hugo Chávez es un referendo revocatorio
en el año 2004 no obstante para otros
especialistas los orígenes de esta
crisis se ubican en el año 2005 cuando
en aquel entonces la oposición decidió
no participar en unas elecciones
parlamentarias señor Joel le pregunto
por qué la abstención en las
parlamentarias de 2005 profundizó los
problemas políticos en Venezuela eso
hablamos de dos oposiciones incluso de
dos factores de la oposición porque
el sector que se fue por la vía de la no
participación de la extensión permitió
en el 2005 que el oficialismo ocupara
todas las curules de la asamblea
nacional Esos fueron los resortes que le
permitió al gobierno entonces agarrar
para sí todas las instituciones del país
el tribunal supremo de Justicia del
Consejo Nacional electoral la fiscalía
general de la república la contraloría
es ir todo el por el los poderes
republicanos pasaron a manos Solamente
del gobierno no obstante otro nutrido
grupo de especialistas sostiene que la
crisis política en Venezuela se originó
con la llegada de Nicolás maduro al
poder en el año 2013 tras la muerte de
Hugo Chávez pero esta situación Se
incrementa en 2018 cuando Nicolás Maduro
lleva adelante unas elecciones que no
fueron reconocidas Por una parte de la
comunidad internacional y que además de
reconocer Entonces al expositor Juan
guaidó en enero de 2019 como presidente
interino de Venezuela generó sanciones
en contra de funcionarios e
instituciones del país que ya venían
imponiéndose desde el año 2015 en este
sentido quisiéramos consultarle a
nuestro invitado Qué impacto generó en
el país la división dentro de la
oposición en el proceso electoral del
año 2018
en la propia reelección del presidente
maduro en el 2018 es la no participación
de una buena parte de la oposición
venezolana y
el acusar al entonces candidato Henry
Falcón de colaboracionista de
facilitador del proceso de consolidación
y La Búsqueda del desconocimiento de
Nicolás maduro como presidente de la
república es que todo un histórico de
errores de marchas y contramarchas
que hoy
insisten y persisten pero señores vemos
Que Nicolás Maduro está tomando fuerza
con la flexibilización de las sanciones
y además él debe acercamiento que ha
tenido con otros mandatarios entre ellos
el presidente Emmanuel macron de Francia
es esto posible de Cara a un proceso
electoral
Entonces no solo fue macrón
después ha sido cada uno de los jefes de
estado de las distintas naciones
europeas y por supuesto el gobierno
Norteamérica que no iba a permitir que
solo Irán Turquía Rusia en China manejen
los negocios en Venezuela Entonces
eso le ha dado fortaleza evidentemente a
presidente maduro eso
le va a permitir
ir desmontando el tema sancionatorio y
evidentemente vemos como ya la cepal
reconoce que Venezuela carecerá entre
dos y tres por ciento el año próximo
económico a pesar de los esfuerzos son
los venezolanos los que siguen
padeciendo los problemas derivados de la
confrontación de sectores políticos y
ante los problemas económicos además de
las sanciones impuestas contra el
gobierno venezolano y alguno de sus
funcionarios muchos han decidido emigrar
a otros países un Éxodo que de acuerdo
con la agencia de la ONU para los
refugiados ya se ubica en 7,1 millones
de venezolanos
Pero toda esta crisis política ha traído
como consecuencia problemas económicos
en un país que de acuerdo con la
Organización de Países exportadores de
petróleo OPEP cuenta con la mayor
reserva probada de crudo desde la
llegada de Nicolás maduro al poder en el
año 2013 la economía venezolana ha
perdido un poco más del 80% de su
producto interno bruto pero luego de
siete años de contracción el fondo
monetario internacional indicó en su más
reciente informe de perspectivas
económicas emitido en octubre de 2022
que Venezuela podría registrar un
crecimiento económico para este año
adicionalmente en abril la comisión
económica para América Latina y el
Caribe cepal Indicó que Venezuela podría
registrar un crecimiento de cinco puntos
porcentuales y el Banco Central de
Venezuela que Durante los últimos años
no ha sido muy consecuente con la
publicación de datos Y además ha
impedido que los medios y especialistas
independientes accedan a ellos estimó un
crecimiento de
18,7% en una declaración
a finales del mes de noviembre
a esta hora aprovecho para dar la
bienvenida al economista Leonardo opera
y le consulto es real este crecimiento
que está registrando Venezuela en los
actuales momentos Yo diría que es un
proceso de recuperación todavía muy
incipiente después de ocho años de
depresión económica como no la había
visto ningún país latinoamericano en la
historia contemporánea Entonces en
realidad no no es para ningún para nadie
ninguna sorpresa que finalmente después
de este largo camino de depresión
económica Venezuela comienza a tener un
primer año de recuperación ahora esa
recuperación hay que caracterizarla en
primer lugar yo diría que es una
recuperación basada en el consumo en el
consumo por por dos razones
fundamentales por el hecho de que la
economía se ha ido dolarizando y eso ha
permitido a las empresas sobre todo el
sector privado de remunerar a sus
trabajadores en dólares Así que la
dolarización en cierto modo ayudado a la
recuperación del consumo y por otro lado
también el flujo de remesas en el año
ha sido superior al flujo que se tuvo
durante dos mil veintiuno y eso también
ha ayudado a la recuperación del consumo
lo que no vemos es una recuperación de
la inversión por lo tanto
es un crecimiento que todavía no se
perfila como un crecimiento sostenido
pero la inflación es uno de los
problemas que más preocupa al venezolano
si bien el país salió del ciclo de
hiperinflación de años anteriores se
ubicó en el mes de noviembre en 21,9% es
decir 7,4 puntos porcentuales por encima
de la inflación registrada en Octubre y
que teja en el indicador en un acumulado
de 11 meses en
195,7%, además hay un proceso de
depreciación de la moneda de curso legal
en el país el Bolívar con respecto al
dólar en esa nación la estadounidense
registró un incremento Durante los
primeros días del mes de diciembre de 20
por ciento que trae esto como
consecuencia Pues que el salario mínimo
fijado en 130 bolívares o 29,68 dólares
en marzo de 2022 ha perdido alrededor
del 69% de su valor ubicándose en 9,2
dólares al mes señor Leonardo le
pregunto es posible frenar este proceso
de depreciación de la moneda a las
reservas internacionales de Venezuela
las reservas líquidas las operativas con
las que puedes intervenir en el mercado
son escasas Este es un país que se quedó
sin reservas internacionales hace mucho
tiempo y básicamente entonces lo que
hace el Banco Central en el mercado
oficial que existe en Venezuela es
intervenir puntualmente cada vez que le
llega algún recurso O cada vez que le
puede comprar algunos dólares a la
industria petrolera
un mercado cambiario fluido transparente
profundo
no puede funcionar de esa manera así que
me Temo que hasta tanto a esas
condiciones estructurales no cambian en
Venezuela a qué me refiero con
condiciones estructurales recobrar la
confianza en la moneda Y eso requiere
reformas institucionales importantes que
le devuelvan la credibilidad a las a las
instituciones monetarias resolver los
desequilibrios fiscales los
desequilibrios macroeconómicos
y por otro lado que el país pueda tener
un buffer un stock de reservas
internacionales hasta tanto eso no se
resuelva yo creo que vamos a tener un
mercado cambiario muy inestable durante
las negociaciones políticas en México se
discutió el acceso de Venezuela a unos
3.000 millones de dólares podrían estos
recursos dinamizar la economía
venezolana O podría generar un impacto
negativo
la ejecución de estos recursos es
política fiscal entonces expansiva
habría que coordinar esa expansión a de
recursos en la economía con una política
monetaria o una política que intente de
alguna manera
neutralizar los efectos negativos que
podría tener la inyección de recursos en
la economía una fórmula es no
inyectarlos en bolívares sino
inyectarlos en dólares Recuerda que
Venezuela es una economía ya bi
monetaria de facto Muchísimas gracias
Leonardo por sus intervenciones también
a Joel a lo largo de todo este especial
a ustedes por estar con nosotros 100 o
más de la programación de France 24 y
France 24.com
[Música]